this is a round table in a series of
roundtables titled global governance
around the table today's a new normal
for European security architecture
question mark the vision from the Baltic
Sea region we're very grateful today to
have experts from four countries we have
program but most of them three three of
them are permanent representatives of
their country United Nations we have an
ambassador beyond these mosaics
permanent representative of Latvia to
the United Nations ambassador of the
planet a permanent representative of
Lithuanian to the United Nations and
ambassador well of school permanent
United Nations from Estonia we have dr.
Lau Imam soul who's a professor of
international law we're very fortunate
to have to have you here and thank you
it is so late noticed for for coming he
is also a bestiary fellow at the Wilson
Center in Washington DC the discussion
overall would be moderated by ambassador
unity of gave senior fellow and lecturer
and Yale University and former permanent
representative of Ukraine of the United
Nations again thank you all
Thank You red yeah I also try to be very
short and to give more floor in time to
distinguished guests who are remarkable
personalities big experts particularly
in that on that item in alphabetical
order of the countries starting from
ambassadors so the Yanni's mosaic is
used to come often I misspoke last year
on the challenges to the to the region
so he's well well experienced the
diplomat which did fantastic career he
was advisor to the president he worked
with the European Union on the issues of
security last year he was in a position
to speak on the very important issue the
challenges from the in the information
sphere cyber security but today he will
speak broadly we have a static
ambassador from a little any world of
limited she's also an expert in the
security issues being ambassador to many
countries Spain Argentina she had to the
the the Department of her ministry or
the conflict Prevention's so this is
exactly the question can we prevent any
conflicts in Europe and particularly
that dead zone and of course on my left
a member of the Security Council current
member of the United Nations Security
Council ambassador of Sweden all of
scope he he had an experience in
European Union is why what we are going
to discuss today this exactly in in the
hands of this distinguished diplomat he
coordinated in you common foreign and
security policy this fight will be very
important to hear from him on the
current developments in the region and
I'm so pleased that we have
representative Estonia
professor Laurie Malik so he is
professor of total University
one of the famous in the region and what
is important today he is with a the
Scholar Program in the villain Center
and he's a theme of research is so
important for today's discussion the
public international law especially
history in theory of international law
and the understanding of international
in Russia the the the aim of this
project to examine Russia's approaches
to the legality of the use of military
force in international law legality or
illegality with that I just to remind
you that after historic Helsinki final
act in 1975 the security in Europe and
the depart of the world was challenged
many times including partition of Cyprus
collapse of the Yugoslavia resources
Republic well in the wars in Georgia for
the annexation of Crimea so and the
tensions between the the different
players in in the region in different
spheres and I asked the colleagues at
the table to focus on their statements
and mostly in conversation with the
audience on the challenges in military
political sphere in economic sphere to
look the two services are the challenges
which are coming from certainty or
uncertainty European policy and whatever
we want to trace today will be in the
second part of our meeting with that I
propose to start in the alphabetic order
of the countries starting from the
ambassador's sorry and then then a Sony
colleague finished with that Latvia
Lithuania Sweden and then Estonia
ambassador from Latvia
what's United Nations principle starting
from the member states then the rest of
us yeah yes yes well thank you so much
thank you very much for inviting me and
always pleasure to be back this time we
really have like snow countries that
have quite similar positions on the
security aspects perhaps Sweden is in
slightly different position because
you're the only one who is not a NATO
member but for the Baltic States the
perspectives are quite similar so we had
the chance to talk with my Athenian
colleague that we will not address all
the same issues but try to divide we
just mean that the issues that I won't
be covering are not be important for
listening and vice-versa
so the title of this today's discussion
is the new normals with a question mark
and I think the answer to the short
answer to that is that it it is not the
new normals because for us the starting
point for the present situation is the
crisis in Ukraine the annexation of
Crimea and that is the one element which
is definitely not new normal it can be
the situation on the ground for a while
we were a country that was occupied for
50 years in contravention of
international law but it wasn't the new
normal and this shouldn't be the new
normal either having said that we also
have to see how we work in this new
environment because environment is
really new and in fact the new
environment precedes even the crisis in
Ukraine because in or in 2013 we noticed
that there was a beginning of Russian
military buildup near our borders to
give you
illustration 30 kilometres from latias
border old airbase was revived it was
stuffed with sixty attack helicopters
for whom the flying time to read be
roughly one hour on that time there was
definitely no movement from the NATO
side we were already NATO members back
then because in the whole of the Baltics
States territory the only military
presence were for NATO airplanes which
were patrolling our airspace and only
from that moment we realized that we
have to devote more attention to our own
security and that was also the year when
we started a moderate increase in our
defense spending
well the real game-changer was the
crisis in Ukraine because while
international law is being broken on a
regular basis I mean the UN is not
perfect it has never been this is the
first time since the establishment of
United Nations when one UN member state
has formally annexed the territory of
another and it was a wake-up call also
for those who hadn't woken up in Europe
as well so what we have been doing
nationally is that a we have paid much
more attention to our own security for a
while we had been if not complacent and
at least attaching priority to other
priorities because obviously every
country has competing priorities but
from 2013 we started increasing our
defence spending with aim of reaching
the 2% of GDP which is suggested
percentage of spending on military that
is agreed among NATO partners and
as of this year we have reached this
spending together with Lithuanian fact
so we are 8 all the NATO member states
who are spending at least 2% of our
defence so we are putting our money
where our mouth is but of course it is
not just the money we are also investing
this money on defense procurement so we
are strengthening our radar systems we
are strengthening our air defence
systems we are purchasing anti-tank
missiles we are purchasing personal
carriers which is a long list but it
also signifies that some of these things
were long overdue and we are also
strengthening our National Guard we also
have a National Guard system in place
since their establishment of
Independence however we have seen an
increase in interests among general
population to be part of that National
Guard and the National Guard is being
harmed better than before on the other
hand we have seen that obviously from
military security perspective this is
not a situation that we will be able to
handle alone and therefore for us the
involvement of NATO in our security has
been very very significant and similarly
the key partner our ally United States
engagement in our security has been
equally important and on both counts it
has been very encouraging that the
developments have been positive what I
mean by that is that the NATO has
decided that it would also have support
on the ground for the allies that are
bordering Russia but at the same time
attention
has been paid to not overdo it basically
not to create a pretext or feeds say ill
thinking that this is NATO preparing for
some aggression against Russian
interests so the measures were really
really proportionate the decision that
has been taken is to establish the
so-called enhanced forward presence in
the three Baltic States and Poland and
in each of the countries it has a
battalion size which is slightly over
1,000 men and women what makes it
slightly unusual also for NATO is that
unlike the usual formations where you
have one country one formation that
these are multinational in each of the
countries there are a number of allies
involved in Latvia I think is the
largest number I think it is seven
allies and in each of the countries
there is a lead nation it is United
Kingdom in Estonia Canada in Latvia
Germany in Laveen and in the United
States in Poland so what is rather
obvious by the list of these countries
that these are the four big countries of
NATO which means that on the one hand it
is clear that it is just 1,000 armed
troops that cannot present aggressive
force on the other hand it is a
meaningful formation that it can be
engaged if necessary and be that it is
force that represents something bigger
it presents big armed forces of
countries engaged bigger and if I began
small of all the NATO partners 20 are
engaged in the Baltic States and Poland
including the host nation
and the other element that we have been
also happy to see is that that we have
seen continued support by Ori to u.s.
administration's for our security it
started in the previous administration
when after the annexation of Crimea the
NATO air patrolling was increased by
several planes it was a symbolical step
but very important to mark all stepped
by United States in 2014 but what we
have seen since then is that there is a
presence of American forces on a
rotational basis which means that they
come for some exercises it's perhaps a
couple of hundred or personnel they do
the exercises together with all around
forces they leave and then they're the
new group comes in and of course the
Americans are also engaged as lead
nation in Poland enhanced for presence
and maybe because of this enhance for
presence and American presence our
population was much less nervous than it
would have been otherwise this fall
because every four years Russia has
major military exercises called support
which means waste it again is not
something unusual in itself every army
has a exercises what we and our allies
are not that comfortable with is that
every time the scale of the exercise is
underreported usually it is said that it
is less than 13,000 which is under the
threshold under above which you would
need to invite international observers
however for the outside observers it has
been clear that this number is at least
several time
hire another element that has been worth
some is nature of the exercise because
some of it has engaged paratroopers
landing on and previously of even
preventive nuclear attack well you get
the idea why this doesn't look really as
defensive exercise but since these
enhanced forward prisons battalions were
they're already operational then the
population wasn't particularly concerned
not more than usually and exercises
pasts and that is the end of the story
for the time being so from my
perspective I wanted to touch upon two
more security aspects one is energy
security where I think we have seen like
with the military security some good
developments because in the past our
region has been quite dependent on
Russian energy sources but what we have
seen lately is that a there is new
possibilities to have energy supplies
because there is a LNG terminal in
Lithuania be we there it has not been
also in the past as dramatic as it has
sometimes sounded because for instance
in Latvia we have a huge underground
storage capacity which can last for our
needs perhaps two years so it's not
something that would be over overnight
anyway but what has happened in the
meantime is that there have been no
interconnections also in electricity
grid for instance with with Sweden there
is ongoing work on the the
monopolization of our energy market and
also
on the interconnectedness of the gas
market so it is work in progress but I
would also note that we are among the
countries that are skeptical about the
need for a new North stream to gas
pipeline because what we see is that a
European gas consumption is falling and
B there are already two gas pipelines no
existing North stream and the gas
connection which goes through Ukraine
and none of them is used at full
capacity so one may wonder what is a
Kannamma correction level to have a
third one especially in a situation when
this does not improve the
diversification of the energy resource
sources for Europe as a continent and
finally one element is that for us part
of our geographies that are on one of
our neighbours is Sweden and Finland is
not far away so cooperation with Sweden
and cooperation with Finland both
individually and through NATO is very
important but I would perhaps leave it
at that how the domestic debates develop
there because usually it's not a good
idea when Outsiders start giving advice
so I would stop here thank you what a
pity to share with us thank you very
much
before you said TV experts I don't know
I mean it's too much I think we among
hacks person who really studied in that
what we can say more from our experience
I think personal experience and working
experience and I can't even coming here
I couldn't stop remembering and and
comparing how it was the situation in
world when we started to work in the
Ministry 1994 1993 so it was motive 25
years ago or it's my second time in New
York I just arrived in August so I'm
quite new one in the US and the UN but
it was here from 1999-2002
so that always especially this ottoman
was listening to general debates in the
in the UN as well that was flashes from
the memory how much the world changed as
well the wording even at the UN I think
somebody made research that checked this
time probably all the p5 talked about
the Cold War during the General Assembly
or something so I wouldn't say that only
our security situation our region
changed the world changed in general
something like that so we are hostages
and everything all the threats which for
many countries I think we're facing as
well and of course looking and at the
math which we have behind us the
situation our biggest neighbor Russia
during these decades from the collapse
of the Soviet Union and nowadays has
changed and that's very much
somehow change our security situation
during they say Yanis talked about game
change situation in Ukraine I think that
was wake-up call and opening of our
voice why you have that the country the
21st century Europe some country can
lose its territory in the period of
weeks or months in that or to have
establish open calm conflicts so that
changed not only perceptibly countries
but I think what changed also our
population and understanding as well so
that the threat and the situation is
completely different than it used to be
when you think most electrically and
everything is one thing but you realize
that in your neighborhood changing
something so makes you change as well
Yanis also talked about the real
military security which is very
important and we do our best as well to
do we notice the
much more concentration of Russian
military troops around our countries
here if you see the the map as well
Ellis wearing especially was Poland we
are next to Kaliningrad region which is
one of the most militarized regions in
Europe and they have 25,000 troops so as
some say the missiles as well something
so nobody knows probably fro for for 100
or something course but that's really
it's one of the security challenges so
that's why we also very grateful and
here for the US and NATO that the
situation also changed from that science
that we are members of the NATO we have
NATO presence in in Lithuania the
Germans are the leading nation which
starts and that's very much appreciated
and very well accepted by the population
and I underline that it will speak about
why I mentioned that it is very much us
in Poland as well so it's never for
forgetting and so we remembered as well
that they are us today which one of the
corner stones of our security and that's
but a part of the military security what
we face as I think in all the world
hybrid threats and it's not only
military but what we face well this
information
really all information was as and fake
news in Europe is used completely
different I think has different
connotations and he in the US so for us
it's really big threats because of
deaths or hybrid versus cyberattacks
Young has thought about energy misuse
but all other issues so and I think that
is also very important that the
countries in a not only Baltic States we
very happy that the EU NHS well that
taking into account they do realize that
is one of the biggest challenges and
threats as well and not only for the
Baltic States for the whole Europe as
well or NATO countries and he wanted to
me be more disabled disinformation and
campaigns what we noticed reading the
last year's Russians big increase with
all the efforts and money and all the
different means really to put how doubts
in the society and to use all the means
to to shaken values of the Western
values the trust of the people in our
countries and to have disseminate all
different news that's very good we are
very happy in the Yuda was created
Stratcom
task force in many of our countries also
we have Stratcom strategic communication
units which they are trying to detect
such information and to take preventive
measures as well or or counter this
information spreading the real
information and this information is not
so how to say obvious and very easy to
to notice i mean if somebody writes the
article or russian TV speaks how NATO is
bad or something like that so that's
that's already all time probably
propaganda nowadays propaganda is much
more sophisticated and and better used
usually that goes by adults putting the
doubt where it really is that
or disseminating many contradicting news
so the people would lose what is really
the reality and the true story something
of that so and what we know this is not
only against each country or different
not always that's what is it's
furthermore directed against the basis
of European or Western values against
NATO values against EU as well so here
we would as well very looking for very
supporting the cooperation between
countries and what I thought I said we
started that in the EU but also this day
was base all the Western partners and
that has to be tackled because the nose
in Russia has and Russian today is
poking news I think I have you even
watch here on the TV so in the US TV is
about that so but what the service that
can't just have its much smaller
resources but it's good that recognition
all they need to work in this direction
is there and I think we have to to do
another you should stay cyber attacks
and cyber security
what is is also now nowadays all the
economy all our infrastructure and
everything is very much based on IT in
Internet and everything so it's a big
advantage that helps us a lot
it is also source of some insecurity it
might be very much and it's not only
from Russia we know that from other
countries as well goals so here's well
the at least in this way an iPad and now
in many countries as well there was
national security cybersecurity task
host created to the taxation for my
earth such attacks and related to assist
or to if such a taxes and when you
notice you in the last year there is
three times more attacks cyber attacks
usually people maybe not even notice
where you have good systems and good
protection or five times more it's about
like spying attacks really trying to
find out how the infrastructures further
they well prepared or another tool pet
or something like that
so under SWAT you see it should be very
much taking here in the futures well and
here would like to mention me the one
one example in in the European framework
in European in the EU the worst rated
Pascal senior cooperation to under
security on on defense and security
issues
so lasagna is one of the leading
countries well established Rapid
Response Team exactly on cyber security
so which would be the experts from
different countries working together
trying to detect why is the weakest link
or what is that's so preventive measures
but also assisting in helping to assist
to restore system after such as attack
happens as well now that NATO is also
working on that very heavily so I think
does would be the future of of
cooperation as well and even those
reason may be that just before the
turret even in the beginning of this
year for instance in Lithuania the worst
air fake news published by was hacked
one of the our news agencies and they
said about how Minister of Defence some
very strange things that about his
sexual or something like that some very
how to say information this draws
attention to everybody but it's not only
to great mistrust about the person where
how it was worked out but there was
attachments to that news but which were
infected by some viruses or trying to
penetrate some computers and Internet
information system so how everything now
is interconnected interrelated is good
that it was detected in the first
minutes
first hours there was no damage or
something but to detect that so
everything should be done and that's and
another thing the last one because they
see my ten minutes already raining hard
there's so many things to say on this
made after that on the in question
session on the resilience of the society
if you don't have resilient society and
really people who understand that so we
can have many measures and strengths but
that will not reach so I think that is
also one of the tasks and one of them
good things and what I mentioned what I
started the Ukraine was wake-up call so
it was wake-up call not folk only
government and officials but it was also
for the society and now since I didn't
talk maybe too much about for instance
water made they use very much trolls for
the disinformation campaign thing time
fake think tanks blogs or something like
that so it lets wane it went not trolls
again trolls elves movement so the
people in the Facebook is our I think
our generation who still remembers how
it used to be in the Soviet Isles or
something but already still younger
something so they started to create
encounter trolls also some campaign and
putting more information and doing
active things so and it gained some
results as well there were already
published how bad the elves are some
things are doing so I think that's all
these small steps which are taking place
taking in I think that's also great the
strength and security and our that so
maybe briefly diet enough thank you
thank you to touch upon later so you
know I'm addressing to good friend
ambassador of Sweden out of school thank
you very much thank you thank you very
much good afternoon everyone it's really
very nice to get out of Manhattan and to
meet real people and and to get out of
the UN's meetings room meeting rooms III
will i will i think address this from
concentric circles starting a little bit
from the swedish perspective which is
johnny said is little bit different
because we're not a NATO member and then
talks very shortly about Nordic Baltic
Cooperation I want to say something
about the Arctic because I think it's
very important to see what's happening
there and the EU as you mentioned jury
and then actually there is a UN aspect
to all this as well I think so I just
want to try to get all that into ten
minutes so first let's not forget that
the map to show here is interesting
because it shows the most probably the
most prosperous modern part of the world
the these countries that we represent
here our open economy is going very well
for us
highly educated people open to the world
market economies etc democracies affect
the human rights model countries for
many but we only see the edge of Russia
here and Belarus which are the two
exceptions in our region that are have
no soft power whatsoever and that as my
colleagues have said are actually
especially in the case of Russia is
turning upside down some of the
achievements made in our part of the
world and especially in terms of in
terms of security I think the way to
address this is is security wise to
strengthen what we do our defence etc
but also to look at ways of cooperating
and pulling especially the Russian
people into a closed
understanding of the values that we have
etc including to see the the the virtues
of open and democratic society is a
market economy etc we are not a NATO
country so we've had to sort of rely on
on our own in a way that's why we have a
fairly strong traditional defence we
have a defence industry by the way not
always easy for a country that has also
high moral standards in terms of
lecturing on human rights etc on the one
hand on the other side we need to sell
our weapons in order to maintain our
industry that's another debate but I'm
just saying you know in that has been
traditionally discussed we are not
necessarily neutral country that we are
non-aligned we're not members of NATO
but I want to make absolutely clear and
sometimes this is not well understood
that we are you know very we're at the
core of Western Europe you know we sit
we belong into the as I said you know
the the the the NATO way of thinking the
the the American the transatlantic
agenda there's no question you know
we're not neutral in the sense that we
are you know completely objective
between Russia and the United States
it's just that there has not been
popular enough support for us to join
NATO and over the years it's also been
felt that a neutral policy has actually
served in creating deterrent or
stability in a region of the world which
has been quite hot especially during the
Cold War so the starting point for us
has been a strong defence as I said but
also a outreach in terms of trying to
pursue to have a dialogue and I want to
say on on right now there is a change in
the way we see the security and there
are three or four aspects which is
contributed to what we see as
deteriorating security environment in
our part of the world has been mentioned
I mean
the Russia challenging the European
security order by the annexation of
Crimea and let's not forget it a a
ongoing violation of the territorial
integrity of Ukraine not just Crimea
annexation but also you know maintaining
troops and support to in in Donbass and
the east east of Ukraine there is also
and frost it's extremely important this
is also case for the Georgia war that
you know a country that democratically
decides to move away from the Soviet
sphere and move into NATO you know we're
not an aid to remember well we would die
for defending the right of every country
to choose their own security so so
Russia has absolutely no veto in in
where the former Soviet Union countries
term and and that is a very important
security strategy that an accomplishment
that needs to be maintained now the
second threat that we see is that how
Russia is is in its posturing and
Johnnie's mentioned this is very
aggressive and we see that in in the
Baltic Sea area where you know we have
confrontations on a very frequent basis
in in the air space we have you know the
build-up of medium-range weapons and and
all of that comes also with the rhetoric
from Russia a security doctrine which is
much more aggressive than it has been
and some of these weapons by the way our
medium and medium range so we're not
talking about intercontinental missiles
we're talking about weaponry and that
really is aimed at threatening the
Baltic countries and also our own
security and then we have this whole
distant attacks that we see the cyber
attacks etc but also you know the debate
you're having in your country in the
United States about how Russia tries to
influence the outcomes of democratic
elections plenty of elections coming up
in Europe including in my country this
year and we're very concerned about how
Russia will try to push that in a
direction which would serve their
interests through various sneaky cyber
and other
less hidden propaganda which as other
was saying today is much more
sophisticated and used to be I just want
to say what about the Arctic it doesn't
show on the map here but let's not
forget that the climate change which is
real is making the waters of Arctic open
there are now and that's you know a
changes the to teach outlook for those
of us who have Arctic parts of our
countries Russia is making very
aggressive use of this they are building
up I I saw the figure of 40 new
icebreakers that have been added to the
Arctic fleet of Russia they are they
have now deepwater ports they have a new
Arctic command they are making
operational several of the airfields in
this part of the world so this is just a
new security threat at least to be
looked at we are responding by
increasing our defense expenditures
considerably we are putting permanent
troops on Gotland the biggest island in
the Baltic Sea that is Swedish Ireland
we are increasing our NATO or
cooperation we are accreting military
security cooperation with the Baltic
countries with Finland and another
non-native country etc so the paradox
here is that one of the strategic
interest for Russia is for Sweden and
Finland to stay outside of NATO but the
more they push the more aggressive they
become our public opinion is turning
towards a more NATO favourable you know
approach so what I want to say so this
is sort of how we meet this in a
security and the heart security but
there's also to us important that we use
the organizations that exist including
the Nordic Baltic cooperation of course
to always compare notes and to meet a
lot which we do including in the UN by
the way but we do also have cooperation
organizations as you know and starting
you know from the concentric circles in
our neighborhood it's really the Baltic
Sea Council which comes to mind and
Sweden happens to be
the chair of the Baltic Sea Cooperation
Council and what is important here is
that Russia is part of it and not just
the Russian government but there are
several sort of sub groups etc that are
quite concrete as I said we have a we
have an interest in pulling civil
society you know supporting civil
society in Russia people-to-people
contacts but so that's a way of
long-term working to change the way the
Russians see their their US and the
world but it's also some very concrete
issues we have with with Russia the
quality of the water in the Baltic Sea
has been suffering a lot from the
Russians you know various industries on
the calm side of Gulf of Finland etc and
and so we we have an interest in
ensuring that there is cooperation in
terms how we govern how we sustain the
environment organized crime is a huge
problem in our countries and much of
that is also a Russian issue and we try
to sort of find ways to deal with that
so our public opinion is keen that there
is concrete cooperation with Russia in
terms if that could help to improve some
of these issues moving just on the next
sort of concentric circle is the
European Union I I think it's it's if
I'm very open with you I mean I used to
work in the European Union it's a couple
of years ago now but I do think that it
is problematic that the European Union
is bogged down with constant internal
difficulties right now it's the brexit
issue which is a huge problem both
because it takes away a lot of political
energy for the EU to maintain its
incredibly important historic role in
creating stability and peace and
prosperity in Europe I think Baltic
friends would agree with us that that
has been maybe the the the single most
important Organization for creating
peace after the world
in Europe that's how we see it a peace
project that's why we always always been
in favor of an enlargement that the EU
should spread it should open up to new
members being the Balkans Turkey our
Baltic friends and I remember a meeting
I took part with the president of France
at the time she rocked with the Swedish
Prime Minister and the French president
at the time Chirac he was you know
sceptical about opening up the European
Union you know adding the Baltic
countries that just sort of brought in a
problematic relationship with Russia
that's how they saw it and my Prime
Minister I'm very proud of what he said
he said look you're wrong
actually Europe has become a better
place since we open up for those
countries and the European Union has
been richer by adding countries who
understands Russia it understands the
potential threat of Russia so but I
think that debate is still is still out
there and as I said I regret that EU is
not really capable today because of the
internal quandary is to do the kind of
work that we would like them to do but
we are all together supporting a more
permanent structure cooperation also
when it comes to military cooperation
we're inside the European Union and that
the fact that UK is pulling out not only
does it take away energy and the
importance of the European Union right
now but I'm afraid that it also means
that we together are losing an ally in a
way because the United Kingdom has been
I think with us when it comes to the way
we see they have been more skeptical
about Russia then maybe the French and
the Germans at times and so this is part
of why I think brexit is very very bad
for Europe and I think whatever happens
with that maintaining a close
relationship with the other Kingdom has
also security aspects of it that remain
important finally maybe just to say that
you know for us
it's also important that we take this to
the security to the Security Council to
the you to the global level because in a
in a situation with such a powerful
neighbor as Russia we have to rely on
the rule of law in international
politics that international law is
respected and the main sort of upholder
of international law is still the United
Nations Security Council we are we are
serving on the Security Council right
now or I represent my country and we are
constantly in our in our you know in a
backbone and reflexive you know as a
reflex always defending international
law and if we don't uphold it in you
know the South China Sea or also with
the United States by the way acting
according to not nurse law it makes us
more it makes more difficult for us to
argue that also visa vie Russia that
becomes important it's the security
point for us for us the same is true
about trying to prevent conflicts before
they break out something they we have
been very bad at defending human rights
globally defending a freedom of
expression globally all of this we do it
on a global level but we always do it
also with the concern of Russia and the
same by the way it's the discussion
we're having with the United States
about free trade not being protectionist
not you know being nationalistic it was
all of that the u.s. goes nationalist
that will the same will you know be
supported by Russia and that creates
instability in our part of the world so
that's why I think the concentric
circles are important too you know we
naturally Baltic Cooperation Council
European Union an extremely important
but let's not forget that the UN remains
important also in upholding
international law thank you
first of all I would like to thank you
ambassador Sergei F and the whole
McMillan said Center for for inviting me
it's a pleasure to to be it on this
panel and and I'm actually currently
doing some research on small states in
the in the UN Security Council so it's
very very very fascinating for me to to
be on the same panel with these with
these ambassadors in particular and I
will try then to link this question of
the security in the Baltic Sea region
with with my specialty which is
international law and in the history of
international law because some of you
may perhaps get this impression from our
panel that you know here are those small
states they are living in the shadow of
over big states and then they complain
they feel insecure they they they you
know feel that the big one is
threatening to them but what can
actually be done about this because this
is the nature of things small ones have
always been afraid of the of their of
their big ones my argument is that this
this the security situation in in the
Baltic region it actually does go beyond
that and then concerns in a way world
order it concerns this what has been
agreed upon in 1945 and what what what
this steel was back back then what we
call international law or contemporary
international law what are its basic
rules and the problem which I see as as
a historian because Stalin's Soviet
Union in 1945 in terms of you know let's
say in terms of values or in terms of
weight came from it it reached it came
to this United Nations Charter from a
different perspective so when we talk
about security then actually you know we
wouldn't need NATO if we could all rely
on international law the main norm of
the United Nations Charter is our t
article two paragraph four the universal
prohibition of the use and threat of
force
there are two scholars of your
distinguished University who have
published an interesting book on that
historical genesis of this prohibition
of the use of 4/4 sooner Hathaway and
Scott Shapiro the internationalists to
the predecessor of this UN Charter was
the Paris pact of rant Keller packet of
19 1928 so so that's the main rule of
the UN and there are two or two
exceptions really the the self defense
if an armed attack occurs and secondly
the collective decision of the of the UN
Security Council where of course then
our our great neighbor participates as a
permanent member of the Security Council
even after Sweden will be gone from that
from that body and Latvia hasn't arrived
there yet and the difficulty of course
is that we start the story with with
Ukraine but when you when you listen
when you read Russian policy texts on on
international law and international
security then they are complaining about
the United States they are complaining
about NATO and they are saying that it
was the West that started to violate
international law first after 91 in in
in the Kosovo intervention when actually
a popular argument about Western
international lawyers in spring 99 was
that that what we are doing here forming
Yugoslavia is perhaps not legal but it's
it's legitimate so there was no UN
Security Council decision on that and
and then secondly Iraq war 2003 and then
Russia also claims that NATO powers you
know they went beyond their mandate with
intervention in Libya in 2011 and and
this is to some extent how they what is
used as kind of excuse for Crimea it's
it's sort of you know if you guys can
violate international law why can't we
and and you know we have to we have to
think what is what is the what is the
Western argument what is the argument of
the Baltic states about about about this
is Estonia situation is is almost
completely identical with with Latvians
and Lithuanians with one tiny
tiny exception we with we do not have
actually a very firm ratified border
treaty with Russia it was signed
basically a week or two weeks before
little green man appeared in Crimea in
Moscow so it has been signed but
recently foreign minister Lavrov said
that the press conference that Russia is
not currently considering ratifying it
because of the bad atmosphere of
relations my problem is let's say
historian international law is that that
you know this for from Moscow V's
viewpoint you know having these these
these Baltic lands a separate lands you
know detached from from from Russia
doing their own thing has has in itself
been been been a negative security
situation for centuries so the whole I
don't know sixteenth seventeenth
centuries is a history of of armistice
ease and and various treaties that get
concluded and violated with with old Lee
with with Livonia and later later Sweden
that that came to control these lands
there so that is that is a potentially
you know if if Russia would want to
prove currently also in the context of
sanctions that it's it's it's it does
have goodwill that it does not have you
know let's say bad intentions in this
region then I you know if I were in in
the Smolensk ploshad which is the
location of the Russian Foreign Minister
and I would consider actually pushing
for the ratification of this treaty as a
as a starter although then then we have
also the example of Ukraine namely some
of you may not know but Ukraine and
Russia actually had a ratified porter
treaty which was ratified 2004 so the
annexation of Crimea was not only
violation of general international law
but also bilateral international also of
course this key kind of makes you makes
you pessimistic as a smaller neighbor
state of Russia what is the value of
treaties and and you know it's it's
since 2004 I think president Putin's
team cannot say that it was there you
know a weak predecessor or something now
it was that it was the same same team so
coming back to this UN Charter as as a
system
the big debate currently between the
United States and and Russia is really
about what is the what is this 2018
interpretation of global security and
international law because because one
aspect that some sometimes forget is
that international security never
started to function in a way that it was
envisaged by the drafters of the UN
Charter in the sense that there were no
for example no armies were put under the
UN UN Command collective collective
security quickly became regionalised and
the biggest red flag for for Russia of
course is NATO so they subjectively
perceive when someone comes closer to
Russian borders with certain military
cap capabilities then this is somehow
this is in itself bad and and what you
said is of course that what we share in
the Baltic States that everybody
everybody gets to decide to themselves
where they belong who protects them but
this is not how Russia perceives it
Russia perceives it and you know Newt
Gingrich the American politician said
that Tallinn is a is a bond layer or a
suburb of of of Petersburg you know and
that's that's how they perceive it and
of course constructing it the way Russia
constructs its own history with the west
Napoleon and Hitler you know they come
they encircle Russia and then they at
some point they attack they tell you
nine stories of how they promote peace
and democracy but actually they want
thrush as natural resources and so on so
on so forth and we can say that oh how
can you think think like that this is so
stupid but but this is international
relations that is that is how they think
and we have to somehow take into account
that also of course an outsider would
say that Russia did accept in a kind of
you know it was not a happy about it but
it did accept the Baltic States becoming
the member member states of NATO what
became problematic for Russia probably
or when they start to intervene
literally was was was first giorgia and
then you know Ukraine because so they
drew the red line somewhere and then now
the question for the West is also you
know do we do we kind of accept some of
these red lines but of course this is a
this is horrible news for for example
Ukraine into two to even even even you
know consider that what might de facto
lead to some sort of splitting of
Ukraine's territorial integrity which of
course international lawyers cannot
support like that I leave it here and
and thank you for events in the past so
I found it among my papers the
interesting address of the former
Minister cause arrived in Stockholm
during the conference on Security and
Cooperation in Europe it was December 14
1992 he had two parts of his statement
the first one I am taking just the
following according the space of the
former Soviet Union cannot be regarded
as a zone of full application of CC
norms in essence that this is a post
imperial space in which Russia has to
defend its interests using all available
means including military and economic
ones
there shall strongly insist that the
former USSR Republic joined the new
Federation of configuration without
delay and there will be tough talks on
this matter
40 December 1992 then we remember that
in 1993 Russia Duma adopted a law
recognizing Crimea as the part of Russia
Federation then we defended our right in
the Security Council because of the
conflict between Yeltsin and his Duma
but a mere Tuzla we had everything
now we approached interesting situation
in December
United States adopted its national
security strategy defense strategy in
January national security strategy
reaction from Russia very interesting
from the leading experts in the gear
strategic and the advises to the to
President Putin Kerrigan of you know
this name and in editor-in-chief on
Russian foreign policy magazine fellow
rukia know the title Trump's defense
strategy is perfect for Russia quote
many Moscow seem to like this it reminds
them the Cold War when things were quite
clear and everyone know how to behave
all the coolest day the core it brought
many many examples of the confrontation
with Russia between NATO and Russia and
the natural question is coming has a new
Cold War started or did the old Cold War
ever end
I mean ambassador foreign ministry cause
Arif in retrospect is seen as the most
pro-western of Russia's ambassadors
imagine that if if now what you citation
that you found is actually you know
pretty pretty Imperial yeah so it was a
first part of his statement and because
the second the second and he explained
what I said would happen if those who
are in the parliament the Communist
nationalists and others will lead Russia
in that way but what he said happened in
few years after he provoked the
discussion inside the this conference of
course he was of a different point
you and his doctrine of the
internal/external policy foreign policy
field and in the parliament they adopted
few doctrines on the military and on the
foreign policy which were absolutely in
line what he quoted in his first
statement it means that the foreign
policy of democratic Russia never
happened from the very beginning or the
paper in the reality if I may add on the
Cold War because it's just having that I
was invited to a discussion which was
called whether the Cold War has ended or
whether it is back and my answer to that
is that eight had really ended and be
it's not really back because with all
the difficulties that we have we are not
where we used to be and thanks God for
that you can see some parallels like for
instance the Doomsday Clock which you
know American scientists have been
measuring how far from midnight we are
from the Domesday when all hell breaks
loose and the nuclear war starts it had
sent back to 17 minutes to midnight
which had never happened in mid 90s as
of January this year we are back to two
minutes but it's primarily not because
of our region but because of North Korea
so if you look at what we had in the
Cold War when you had huge armies facing
each other where you had radio jamming
where you had no freedom of woman you
don't have any of those elements we have
some rhetoric we have propaganda we have
attempts to counter this propaganda
through strategic communication but I
still would hope that we are not at the
stage of cold war and I also hope that
we're not getting there okay yeah I
agree I agree with the Johnnies I think
also I mean
Oh partly because the the Cold War was
in a global level where you had you had
the confrontation between Russian or
American proxies or directly basically
in every on every continent and we're
very far away from that now I think
there are isolated issues Ukraine and
Syria partly where there is strong
disagreement Ukraine in Syria where
there is a clear disagreement between
Russia and the United States but for the
rest I mean there are there are other
things that are happening including the
the gradual withdrawal of the United
States from from from from the world if
you if you like that's part of the
American doctrine so this and and that
gives space for China you know we should
discuss China we should discuss how
Russia is using the fact that the
Americans are not as assertive as they
have been including in Syria which
creates huge huge problems but I don't
think it's I agree with John is it's not
the Cold War as we knew it there are new
threats as well including the
non-proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction the North Korean situation
and by the way we are as part of why
Sweden Swedes are reluctant when it
comes to joining NATO is also the
nuclear aspect of it that you know that
relying on nuclear with with with Russia
against Russia is something that is
simply not for most Swedes it's just
such a horrendous scenario so and we're
also now we have a debate about whether
whether or not to ratify the nuclear ban
treaty that was negotiated Americans are
pushing us hard not to come close to it
but we were part of those negotiations
when of course NATO members have a
completely different different outlook
family ads I mean cold war is of course
metaphor in the first place because
there's no you know legal definition
what is and what isn't cold war so
therefore and but but but difficulty
that Russia is smooth in Crimea caused
in region is a sort of lack of let's say
erosion of trust for the same reason of
this Budapest memorandum and
you know the border treaty that was in
force so so because you know on an
average panel like that if somebody
before Crimea would have suggested that
Russia is capable of doing something
like that he he he or she would have
considered an extremist but after such a
thing happens after treaties are broken
territories aren't are next and then
it's human and inevitable that one
oxidation what else can you do
where else can you you know intervene or
or or fill out a security vacuum and
it's only in the light of this
background that we have had this kind of
debates like last summer you know will
will the military exercise of ZAP but go
over to some attack I it's not it's not
a normal discussion in this sense and
it's not a pleasant discussion in this
sense we out the panel the title of this
panel justifies itself we live in a you
know let's say worsen security climate
because it would it it's not but at the
same time you know nobody's saved from
this energy the people of Hawaii just
got a message that you know the bomb is
coming security insecurity which is
coming from the nuclear threat so what
we are hearing now from Moscow and from
here that the nuclear deterrence was
good one why not to keep it to keep
having killed and so what does it mean
for the Baltic states that in
Kaliningrad you mentioned among the the
other missile system we have to were
capable to carry nuke nukes never never
happen caliber as 400 the same the
Russian deployed in Crimea so with the
range of coverage around nine point five
thousand kilometers so what is that
let's move further about the European
security so
recently the European Union invented the
new the new idea the new initiatives are
called Tesco which is inviting all the
Member States to forge the security not
only secure about defense interest
through that partnership
it is not alternative to date of course
but is it helpful because it will need
extra spending what do you think about
that yeah I think as I said too that you
support it we said we support it too and
this is a slight change in Swedish we've
been traditionally quite reluctant on
seeing since we are you know sceptical
to NATO then we've also been hesitant to
allow the EU to expand into a military
pact or or strategy but I think again
the Russian posture starting with the
Georgia attacks in 2008 and now the the
Crimea and Ukraine situation has changed
the way we look at this and we do
believe that it makes sense for not for
the EU to sit on its own capacities
military capacities in Brussels to be
you know dispatched by decision in
Brussels but we're in independent
countries are coming together pooling
our resources more defence cooperation
developing more advanced weapons
together in as a union and I think that
also makes sense when we look at where
the United States is going because I
think with this Trump administration has
also shown that the United States is not
necessarily a reliable partner over the
long term in terms of supporting your
Europe in in our and it's also requests
by United States which makes sense that
we all of us pitch in a little bit more
by ourselves and raise our defence
budgets so this is I think logical to
why we are supporting the pesco
yeah I just can add being a NATO country
we are very much but were reluctant to
somehow to have defense within the EU
that we were was really afraid that
would be duplication of of the
activities of therefore said when you
mentioned double costs as well by taking
into account what we talked today about
new threats new new needs as well so I
think we also changed our mind and we
are more now supportive of this I think
it's not but of course I have to be
careful not to duplicate Nate or
something but you complimentary to NATO
or other activities going I mean now
there are so many threats and cyber is
where pesco will be also engaged very
much as well another issue so I think
this really is not to be afraid of
duplication additional cost but on the
contrary to really see where our
advantages of the corporation and the
EULA well why is that and there are many
layers weights release needed and why
can be not really undermined in NATO
cooperation so we have to put all our
thank you if I just maybe between on
different aspect in fact I won over rare
occasions when I would disagree with all
of is about the present administration
because if one looks at facts on the
ground right now with this
administration in our region there has
been more American engagement and with
well it would be difficult to count
which would be the administration that
would have more in fact what where we
saw the withdrawal was attempt of pivot
to Asia because Europe seems so nice and
calm and that was during the previous
administration now we see the American
engagement within NATO and bilaterally
on a strong basis and we are very
encouraged by that but still I would say
that the future of this European defence
cooperation will depend a lot what will
what will happen to America and what
will happen to this American
relationship with NATO and its
commitment in
in Europe I guess that if this
commitment should weaken over over time
for for certain reasons then and III
think that European countries have no
alternative but to develop this this
further otherwise I think that I
actually think that President Trump has
had a good point European Europeans
cannot outsource their security to two
Americas also I I don't I don't blame
him so at least in border defense
strategy and national security strategy
the American Americans they incorporate
who is the allies around the world the
yesterday's message at the Congress also
was very clear as to the very strong
enough telling that but unfortunately
today we are returning to the same
rhetoric as you used to have I can quote
around the world we face rogue regimes
terrorist groups and rivals like China
and Russia they challenge our interests
our economy our values in confronting
these horrible dangers we know that
weakness is the surest path to conflict
and unmatched power is the surest means
to have a true and great defense so Zig
pass in parallel that could be a Russian
quote right yeah so they say we are
hearing from them that's why my question
was we are coming back to the Cold War
we never moved out from that so very
important point that ambassador from
Lithuania pull out and from Latvia about
the energy security or insecurity well
in as to my country so we reused in
different situation of the Russian
policy which who used the energy
as the the two in their foreign policy
well it were used as carrots and sticks
s to Ukraine anything that all the part
of the of the Europe of the Baltic
States they also knew that it's very
dangerous to be dependent on one source
of the of the supply the president of
Lithuania during the Davos forum last
week pointed very clearly that European
Union needs the same the same structure
in the energy sector as the Energy
Council well to to create a savory for
the for the Europe and she objected
definitely the idea of North stream to
as others based on what you said that no
economic reasons how did that well but
it's surprisingly that there is no
unanimity around that because look who
are of the only board of the of the
north - well two German companies it's
okay but there is a MV from Austria
Dutch Shell we have energy from France
so that means that there is no United
position of the European countries on on
the north - I guess that the messages
which was sent by Polish president and
the Lithuanian which is now grown and
discussed will reach the brussels and to
to learn well carefully so I'm going to
leave the floor for for the audience my
dust from operative questions or the
some of the group of central in Eastern
Europe
namely region
or post strongly last year in Rome
during the summit and they insisted to
exclude from the draft drop declaration
the dimensioning of two-speed Europe's
and innovation grad group so this is
something which is interpreted as very
vulnerable they raised the question that
so we are we are pushing not to
two-speed Europe are to to Europe's what
do you think about that I I know that
the Baltic states were reluctant because
they a few of them self comfortable but
the discussion in the region is going
call about two-speed Europe very brief
comment
don't another provocative don't you
think we already have to speed Europe we
think we do have actually true look
Europe is not so United and I mean as it
might look they have euro countries some
non euro countries some via euro country
Sweden not something half Schengen
countries
some are schenken country some are not
so I think it's I mean yeah the fear of
two-speed Europe comes from the past
when I think even from our when we had a
seeking membership but it would be
really in the co of the U or not and how
it would be I think it's not it's a
really question but they will really
have to so fear of the two-speed Europe
it's somehow exists already just we have
to look for the structures and
possibilities that that all the
countries would be involved and could
participate in your as much as they want
or something like that but that's not in
confrontation with something but it's
more inclusivity of some countries in
and agree to do some more cooperation so
maybe it's not so bad either something
like that so it's great great answer so
see you last division group in March
where they come because your argument
for me is very good
[Music]
your question is very interesting
because it happened many times in the
history so in your question is
uncertainty
what both are doing so the the the power
of putting policy is an uncertainty the
power of term is an uncertainty
uncertainty is the the biggest tool in
the inner history all lawyers are always
successful because of the uncertainty of
law it could be read from this side from
this side so this way they are equals in
terms of uncertainty of their policies
until the world is looking at the
transformation to new world order
so this insanity plays both for two
sighs it's my reading one answer is also
in what view one takes on the role of
individuals in the history is you know
because let's say let's take President
Obama and so he was great for us because
he came to Tallinn and had a great
speech in which he said that you know
will the vent defend you and America's
with you and so on but if you if you
take his foreign policy in another
context in Syria
you know he drove some red lines and
then actually when these things happened
chemical weapons were used he did not
intervene in the end so sometimes
actually we don't know how people behave
in certain contexts but yeah I mean
China okay yeah no what I what I think I
referred to because of course we're here
discussing our our region and that that
involves Russia and I think you know I
very much agree with those who say that
also the European Union's steadfastness
when it comes to resisting Russian
pressure is threatened by the economic
and energy dependence in many cases of
some European countries that's that's a
vulnerability and on top of that I think
comes the very sophisticated way that
Russia is trying we know to influence
the outcomes of Elections and I think
that has been seems to be the case also
in this country which maybe is that and
that's also response to your question of
course we are diplomats we are being
filmed so we have to be very diplomatic
about what we say but I do think that it
was very useful for the United States to
allow the various investigations to be
carrying and inquires to be carried out
in an independent way and that's the
virtue of democracies
but if that starts to become become you
know questioned or influenced etc I
think yes it does put a little bit of a
dent into the credibility also when it
comes to the policy misery Russia but
the sorry I'm back and forth here but on
on but and and my point before was that
if the United States turns a little bit
it's back to you know to to world
politics and I understand what Johnnie
says that actually in terms of their
commitment and military investment in in
Europe right now that has not happened
although the rhetoric swen Trump came in
was a bit threatening in that sense but
I'm just I just think that when we
discussed you know whether we are back
at the Cold War or not I think we also
need to understand how Russia and China
not in a coordinated way but the two of
them are filling the the void that
America leaves behind and we've seen
that in Syria I think we're in a very
it's a very frustrating situation in
Syria because two three years ago we
were all saying that Assad was out we
should be out but but the disgusting
thing right now is that he's not and
he's actually stronger and that is
extremely frustrating to you you know
from the security counter poison point
of view as well because it's a war
criminal who is now back in in in force
thanks to being having been backed up by
Russia the Russian intervention changed
everything for Assad it's just a proof
of how Russia fills the void where maybe
the West and the US and the rest of us
and we're talking about the red lines
when not you know pushed there wasn't
enough push back perhaps China is doing
it in a much more subtle way including
economics we used to discuss you know
the the Chinese role in Africa we were
concerned that they as we you know we
were trying to influence African
countries by aid and Human Rights
lectures and all that Russia invests in
infrastructure instead which which is
much more info
but it's not Africa anymore it's also
the Chinese investments into European
countries including Greece and Cyprus
and you know the soft underbelly during
the economic crisis of Europe which made
you know very generous Chinese
investments coming in I mean they they
also bought up some some Swedish
companies including the Volvo is partly
owned by by Chinese companies production
is still in my country and there's still
some swedish engineers there and it
creates a lot of jobs but i'm just
saying that we need to understand souls
also the economics and how that brings
power so i think that's what i was
trying to say you
[Music]
don't bus being the Quebec oh yeah very
clear I would like to be Canada at
distance because the Gordon of Canada he
caddied sure is being agreed in in
London it doesn't mean that our
president should be agreed in Moscow so
no no comparison is that the second to
build the federal-state nothing wrong in
the federalism but for that you should
have a very strong democratic society we
emerge from the feudal type of the
management in our country when the local
leaders together with the local
criminals they manage all the
territories well Yanukovych was of this
kind and many many others before him so
to have to have this kind of the
management to have the federal system
you need to have a very strong strong
democratic society with the strong
economic economic system open market
language issue language issue is very
simple at the beginning of our
independence we gave the first of our
law was on the national minorities where
everybody were promised and even given
the right to
to study to learn language literature in
all the schools
of course it was a big burden for other
budget at that time some of the
neighboring countries they demanded more
give us more radio stations on the
language give us more newspapers for the
national minorities and so on so forth
it is unbearable for any economy to give
these privileges the second Russian all
of us
emerging from the Soviet Union all of us
we are russian-speaking and is
absolutely impossible to define a single
region over you can concentrate the
Russian the russian-speaking population
giving them the status of craddock
second we are to understand that giving
the privilege to one ethnic group or
language group of yeah we could become a
victim of the butterfly effect was noble
effect that hungarians in france
carpathia ukrainian hungarians will
demand the same Romanians will demand in
same in bucovina polish so for that we
need mm and to have this cultural
autonomies we need a lot of Olivia
reforms inside the country to keep them
motivated not to move out because the
cultural autonomy or language of
autonomy it's the first step to move out
that's why it's it's not a time to even
to speak about that about the federalism
the time is about of course
inclusiveness how to make the region
understand that for them it's better to
be in Ukraine without sorry crane it
means that of course of course but
this is exactly exactly the Russian
position today we have they are pushing
the federalization of Ukraine
understanding that fragmentation of
Ukraine or the federal bodies will lead
for dissolution of Ukraine understanding
that some of the some of the regions if
if they are not if we don't succeed with
the democratic reforms building the the
mature society to motivate people be
inside we do not succeed with the idea
of failure ization they insist to give
the the Donbass region not only which is
out of control of Ukraine now but they
hold on bus region to give them federal
status but it does not work because we
don't understand the intentions standing
behind that we will not keep this region
surviving before we bring the the
reforms in Ukraine was probably
Unitarian Ukraine will be the best
solution full of them but to give to
give the federal status to whom because
this is a mixture of ethnicity there we
have in Donbass region the relics of the
Katerina they degrade who deported
Greeks from the Crimea to children bus
so we have a big Greek community there
do they want to be to have the federal
status with whom because they don't bus
is an issue of Russian ethnic groupings
a lot of Polish there after the Second
World War
many of them they appear there and
settle there so but it's not easy to
build the federalism based on the
linguistic linguistic ground absolutely
impossible Russia will insist on the
same in most other countries on the USS
in almost all the Union whether or
Russia so minorities we are too to think
about the
history snowball by by the way what what
what changes in Russia Russia is the
Federal Republic do you think that
Ukrainians almost 3 min or 7 millions of
Ukrainians living there they enjoy their
rights no it means that the the
federalism itself in terms of the German
Federal Republic or Confederation in in
Switzerland very pleasant for for for
language group in in in Switzerland or
in Canada but is it pleasant for the
ethnic groups in Russia
no why because everything Russia centric
who would convince us ourselves do we
need that
well first you know what the the the the
this is what Russia is doing pushing
have friends in Europe to press Ukraine
to accept the idea of federalization for
Europe some of them it would be bad it
to frozen the problem because it is in
our refrigerator not in theirs well and
that's why they are frozen and we are
explaining them as I am explaining to
you no way
linguistic we have the liver is the
linguistic majority for the case nothing
happened
only when the language factor was used
to create a problem so it was created
artificial artificial that's why it's
not no time I will not go with that idea
which is your correctly raised because
it is on the table on the table of some
European capitals who are pushing
Ukraine to find this final solution to
agree with what Russia is doing Russia
created a problem and now the Russian
dictate dictates what this strange as
well as a Russia appeared in Crimea
under the pretext of protecting Russian
Russian speaking population forgetting
that one-third of of people there are of
the Crimea Tatars they have their own
language many Koreans a lot of the
Ukrainians about the protects was taken
like that and during the debates in the
secure account so advise the Russian
ambassador are you going to apply the
same approach to any region of the world
where you define the Russia's T
population in Brooklyn a lot of the
former Soviet people good friends of us
who speaks they have everything if you
if you come to Brooklyn or Brighton
a lot of the shops with the with Russian
advertisement and whatever so it was
very dangerous pretext to be in Crimea
very dangerous and now they are pushing
the same for some of the regions in
Ukraine it will not work the we do
understand the outcomes of if ever
disappears so United States does not
support it and it is not an agenda of
Volcker and his counterparts so this is
not a case can I add one brief thing to
this this comparison I mean you you you
are basically bringing in the example of
Canada saying that look there is this
wonderful country and you know couldn't
you couldn't Ukraine become like that I
think today's reality is that could
Canada be Canada let's say after a major
French military intervention and could
after such an intervention some sort of
very beautiful bilingual constitutional
new reality be created and I think I'm
sure you would admit that it would be
much more difficult thank you so the
last question it's fine
so even it's fine fine thank you very
much for attending here this roundtable
first of all thank you thank you dear
colleagues for your brilliant
explanations of not easy issues we are
living in the dramatically changing and
rapidly changing world thank you let me
[Applause]
[Music]
you